I can't dip it in the milk huh oh you
guys are terrible people I feel like the
dry food is gonna be easier than the
spicy food I feel like I'm gonna win
really yeah I'd rather my tongue fall
off if the mud you be me I was born
competitive and I eat a lot of food so I
think Jamie's in trouble please don't
hurt me
a way we're supposed to eat all of these
all of them as fast as possible and not
drink milk oh my god
very bad and you don't want anything
more you should just drink that I don't
want to lose on the first round bottom
100 wait a minute I didn't even touch it
yet weight doesn't count
oh that burns my note how am I possibly
what it's like your pores are crying oh
my god I feel like I'm breathing like
I'm a childbirth or something this'll be
good with like ranch like to cool your
mouth huh that is hopeful this is the
face of defeat I'm sorry
we're going to just eat hot sauce chin
chin
nope that was disgusting oops if you do
it I don't feel bad about that yes okay
thank you
you're awesome I was being magnanimous
is there something spicy in these
cookies yeah this is a trap
oh yeah I'm cookies oh this is gonna be
really hard you want to do this but does
this I know this count as a sip I'm not
even a competition in this I'm just
gonna just Kevin you tease okay I've
done hard work
can we just same dad yeah can we I can't
do it yes this what you want
this is definitely what I want oh yeah
yeah and just look down happy there's a
good amount that's right there